am i right you are not living in you're
living in florida now
is that right i'm in florida now well
i'm part-time both i'm splitting but i
got out of there with the snow and
uh it was crazy uh by the way down here
in florida
it's people going around like nothing's
going on i mean it's
it's right it's insane so they're
they're acting like
covet's not a problem nothing yeah you
know i mean
you know it's it's mass but they seem to
be okay i don't know right i think when
you
wear a thong to work it's probably hard
to talk someone into wearing a mask do
you know what i mean
it's true you're not covering the other
end
why would you care about it yeah do you
like
i have to tell you i would have a hard
time in florida this is just me
because uh humidity i don't do great
with humidity
my hair collapses i get depressed what
what about you
by the way my body looks like it
wouldn't do well with humidity and it
doesn't do well with humidity
but i love it i crave it i don't know
why i um
i like tropical that's why i didn't like
la i was in la for a long time i didn't
like it
right and uh i'll sit in my car when
it's hot
and like i won't even turn it on for
like a little sauna i don't know why i
like it i
i'm drawn to it maybe it's just my
way of bringing on sweet death yeah yeah
please
uh you can go to a real sauna you don't
have to sit
in a hunt in a hyundai with the windows
closed in florida
there's a better way to do it uh were
you when you lived here you mentioned
you lived here in l.a
some people get freaked out they don't
want to live in l.a because you're
worried about
uh the earthquakes my wife really is
paranoid about earthquakes
so we live out here i don't think about
it she thinks about it all the time
whenever we have one she freaks out did
you do okay with that when you lived
here
no i didn't because um here
you get a hurricane you can see it
coming it's that whole lack of control
thing
i think when i was uh in l.a i had
a couple little rumbles and i'd never
experienced anything like you didn't
like it before so i felt completely out
of control the whole
place is swinging a little you know and
i freak out and i overreact to
every little one now you know like so i
didn't like it at all it wasn't like
i would act like it was the one in 94
right and it would just be a little
shimmer and and i go crazy honestly i
just ripped my shirt off and i would run
outside i don't know the rules by the
way i don't know what you're supposed to
do
no well let me tell you something no one
says take your shirt off in an
earthquake and run outside that's not
one of the no one says to do i think it
is i think it would find the door jamb
and then take your
door jamb the door jam i've heard no one
i've never there's no i don't see take
your shirt off anywhere on this blank
blue card
all right head between the legs take
your shirt off i don't know wet anyway
my shirt was off that sounds erratic
yeah yeah at least you're having a good
time even if the world's freezing
what about so you mentioned hurricanes
hurricanes because i grew up on the east
coast and there'd be a hurricane coming
when i was a kid
i get kind of i know they're dangerous i
get kind of excited when a hurricane
comes
yes it's that you want to go out in the
storm hold on to the pole and see how
long you can
you know get blown away but it doesn't
matter yeah
i i i don't know why because of the fact
that you know
you can see it happening and you can
kind of feel it and you know it's going
to pass and
there is an excitement there's a
challenge to it in a way yeah that i'm
okay with
yeah and you can yeah you can take some
action you can go out and get some
lanterns
you can get a raincoat i don't know
there's some stuff you can do you can
put something over the windows
earthquake what are you gonna do there's
nothing just take your shirt off and run
outside
with that being said i haven't been in
any thank god any devastating
hurricanes which i you know you can
imagine not as fun not good
not good